all right stop right there i have been
asked about this particular scene
so many times and they want to know how
we train
to be able to do that we don't all right
there's so much stuff
that is incorrect in this what's going
on my name is andy stumpf i spent just
under 17 years as a u.s navy seal and i
host the cleared hot podcast today we're
gonna be taking a look at some
underwater action scenes from movies and
seeing how real they really are
one last thing when you hit the water
don't forget to cut away your shoe
ninety percent of people killed during
the halo jump got tangled up in their
shoots and drown
i've never been in an underwater fight
in my life with anybody or thing except
for my own equipment my belts have tried
to kill me magnets have tried to kill me
hoses like you end up fighting all of
your gear so that portion of the brief
was
legit i've never seen anybody
give an
audible brief on an airplane because
it's so loud that you can't hear
[Music]
i am not aware of any real world
operations that started with a parachute
jump of any kind that went directly into
a dive you're probably going to do a
jump where you're pushing boats out of
the aircraft as well the boat lands
under its own parachute you land next to
it you get into the boat and you're
probably gonna have to travel a
substantial distance to actually do the
dive because otherwise you're flying an
airplane directly over the top of where
you're trying to be sneaky and that's
not how you play varsity level hide and
seek right cutting away from your
parachute before you get into the water
is actually really dangerous because
at lower altitudes it's really hard to
judge how high you are
up above the water the rule that we use
wait until your body hits the water to
cut away from your equipment there have
been people who cut away and they
thought they were at 10 feet but they
were at 100 feet or 150 feet and at some
point you know the surface tension of
water can be like concrete and you can
kind of do the math
you don't have to use a flare i mean
they make flashlights
they last longer you don't have to worry
about getting burned
people would actually probably be
a little bit underwhelmed with the type
of diving that you do in the seal teams
not by the volume of diving but it's
very focused on
getting from a to b a lot of it is
navigation to a place where you could
implant a charge or a sensor and then
you're right back out people who do this
type of diving or you know the type of
diving where they're out on coral reefs
it's just a total different experience
most of the diving that i did
was at night and at depths less than 20
feet not accurate at all this is a zero
they actually did some really
um robust breath holding work for this
movie and it's easy to get a long breath
hold like there are people who can hold
their breath for like five six seven
eight minutes it's about the lowest
level of exertion though you don't see
people holding their breath being
incredibly active which is exactly what
he was doing
[Music]
the first introduction to diving
for seal candidates is open circuit in
the pool and i administered the test and
it would not be uncommon to watch
students have a shallow water blackout
or hold their breath until they pass out
and one of the main indicators that
somebody is actually about to become
unconscious is that bubbles will start
escaping their mouth just like he
simulated in the movie so they actually
obviously put their time in to research
this
for
the cinematic aspect and the actual
likelihood of this happening we're gonna
give him like a three and your muscles
will stop working in about 30 seconds
nah i'm sure it's not that fast would
you please listen for once
so this apparently is occurring in the
arctic his uh
operational equipment consisted of a
pair of board shorts and what appeared
to be a messenger bag slung over his
shoulder which is a controversial choice
you spend a good portion of your time as
a student in buds hypothermic i mean
we're talking laying in the pacific
ocean down in san diego sometimes the
water temperatures in the 60s we can get
you hypothermic by keeping you in there
long enough
but that's a different type of cold than
what was being shown in archer like
that's arctic water cold
looked like he was putting a mason glass
explosive charge somewhere inside of the
propeller okay i mean highly improbable
the propeller itself may not be the
the best place to actually put a charge
actually when we would do ship attack
combat swiper operations
instead of actually the propeller itself
the underside of a vessel there's
oftentimes struts and then the drive
shaft that goes out to the propeller and
we would actually put the charges on
the struts itself to structurally damage
the ship's ability work under its own
power or navigate if you blow up a
propeller now i'm not saying that this
is like a nascar swap out fix but you
can put another propeller on if you
damage the structural integrity of the
ship and then the the propeller shaft
is then broken and they have no ability
to reattach that again it's a fixable
problem but now we're talking probably
taking the boat out of the water putting
it into a dry dock and all of those
things so you can get more you know bang
for your buck pun intended i suppose
how explosives are able to work
underwater a lot of them are naturally
very resistant to the elements
c4 is a good example to get c4 to
explode we actually use blasting caps so
that functions under water though just
like it would
uh in the air uh tough to rate a cartoon
i think for accuracy this is gonna have
to be on the lower end i'm gonna go with
the i'm gonna go with the two and the
only reason he gets it two is i like the
homemade mason charge that he somehow
wedged into the propeller
if you need to cross the river
cross the river you know there's no
reason to actually pop up in the middle
of it and give away
your tactical advantage if you are
trying to sneak up on somebody you would
either cross the entire thing above the
water or cross the entire thing below
the water or or
go farther down or upstream
and like you know maybe find a log
that's across it so you don't have to
get wet because being wet sucks
all right stop right there i have been
asked about this particular scene
so many times
because people absolutely love it and
they want to know how we train
to be able to do that
and here's the answer
we don't because right you'd never fall
in any other direction you just
absolutely know the exact place and time
that somebody's gonna fall when you
shoot them in the head right because why
wouldn't you what could possibly go
wrong but you gotta remember all of that
was preceded by probably a 762 or a 300
win mag round
snapping through the jungle the
suppressor that's on the rifle it's
basically a muffler and it contains some
of the gas and it drastically reduces
the decibel output of the rifle but
bullets
when they fly through the air
they're supersonic so it makes a crack
and there is subsonic ammunition
and it's much quieter
that's not what that person was shooting
the whole point of
doing the charade of catching somebody
and lowering them into the water as if
it was just eating them into the abyss
it's because you're trying to be sneaky
so going through all this in attempt to
be sneaky and then
cracking off around in the jungle it
defeats the entire purpose
it's just there's so it's not
how it works people
[Music]
where you link up with a submarine in
the middle of the ocean that's totally
plausible they were on a zodiac which is
going to have probably a 55 or a 35
horsepower
engine so they could easily go from a
land mass over the horizon out into
international water or really wherever
the sub would want to meet and do that
so that's totally legit
yeah wow so they obviously had direct
support from the united states navy to
make this movie
and i'm actually surprised they showed
very much of the sdv which stands for
seal delivery vehicle in essence it is a
miniature submarine it's
smaller harder to be discovered
and you can move people and equipment a
really far distance and then go back to
the submarine too because you can go
back and re-link back up
to that asset that you departed from you
are in your dive gear until that dive is
over and it can be up to 14 hours a lot
of the times you're in dry suits dry and
warm are two very different things that
people should not confuse they nailed it
it's very plausible that all of that
would occur on an sdv operation i'm
going to give them a 10 on that the
sniper water river catch
is a zero it actually might be a
negative number
[Music]
is there a more obvious way to let
somebody know that you're coming
than white and orange parachutes in the
daytime jumping directly over the top of
them surprise you didn't see that coming
i've worn
dive fins on my feet for a free fall
jump and actually was falling through
the air with them on more often than not
though the back strap of the fin you put
your feet through that and you actually
tape the fin
up to your leg but if you're going to
land on the water you're going to want
to have fins on you in case you need to
have the ability to swim or exert
yourself you're going to need those fins
[Music]
yes
and they had a fleet a full fleet of
submersibles
with spear guns i am not aware
of
any engagement at any time in the
history of human beings where anything
like this has occurred
we are not trying to get into fights in
the water like bottom line we use it as
a way to disguise what we're doing or to
get from a to b or to be sneaky right
like well i don't know where they went
like bloop here we are we're in the
water you didn't see a surprise we're
not looking to get into a fight ever
so no we're not bringing tridents or
spears or any of that stuff
[Music]
i like how they're cutting
the uh the hoses unfortunately
there is usually an inhalation hose and
an exhalation hose and they probably can
still breathe if they caught the wrong
one we always had dive knives on us but
it's for like cutting gear if something
gets hung up there was never a thought
in my mind ever of pulling that out with
the intent of fighting with it it was
for anything but that like
phillips head screws using the tip of
your knife like that's the one we use
dive knives for
[Music]
i like the idea of what he's got in his
mouth i'll call that the
gen 1 spare air which with a canister of
that size i feel like you have about one
half of one breath so you certainly
wouldn't be able to stay underwater
[Music]
and then the concussive device in the
water concussion in the way that shock
waves
travel underwater is a very very real
thing let's just say that it was a
grenade of some kind that would probably
kill the people inside of that contained
area
but it probably would damage him a
little bit too especially if there's
open windows and portholes because that
stuff will bounce out as well so
it's plausible but i would say you would
want to get out of there before that
thing went off like out of the water
before that thing went off uh i don't
even know if i can give this one a
technical review
[Music]
so i didn't get a good look at the gun
that he shot that out of my guess would
be probably some version of an m203
grenade launcher
the projectile
doesn't have this continuous propellant
like it did and that and it just pushes
along and the reason you know people
i'm sure want to know if you can fire
guns underwater you can fire a gun
generally one time it just it's they're
not designed to function
in an environment that has that much
feedback from the water you could
probably shoot a 203
underwater but it's not going to look
like that it would probably come out of
the barrel if it even cleared the barrel
and then just drop right off and they
also arm by spinning that's why it has a
minimum arming distance usually of 33
yards so there's a lot of things
that were completely impossible
in that particular scene right there
[Music]
if you just look at how inefficient the
swimming motion was what kills a lot of
your energy
there's two things one they had weapons
slung around them that was very loose
and their shoes it is so hard to swim
with shoes i think that video
highlighted the the the difference
between fins and no fins that's what
swimming looks like when you don't have
fins on and you have shoes that's why
you want to have fins on top of that if
we were jumping and there wasn't going
to be that much swimming i'd go with one
that had maximum flexibility so i could
tape it up and wear the thing as i was
leaving the aircraft if i had to wear
what they had on i'd be pulling myself
along the floor i think it would be
easier and it's very positive and you'd
get more
you'd get more mileage for your effort
that's why you need a knife in that
situation
but they weren't diving so they didn't
have their dive knives with them however
they had a bunch of guns where's i mean
they didn't spend five bucks on a pocket
knife i mean what's going on here
i'm gonna give them a three at best it's
a strength i like reaching for a three
but i'll give them a three
i found door number three
and i'm taking it
[Music]
that's a national treasure all right you
know jumping off of i think it was the
aircraft carrier that's probably going
to be
50 60 feet
i'm here for that that's definitely
survivable you could definitely do that
[Music]
so we navigated
with we called them nav boards and we
had three really exciting items on there
that we used to get to stare at for
hours at a time first one you already
mentioned was a compass
the next entertaining tool was a depth
gauge and lastly
a stop watch
that was it we dive in pairs but only
one person gets the navigation board so
somebody else out there is just like i
hate my life this dive is taking forever
i don't even have anything to look at so
sometimes i was the buddy i would just
swim on top of my dive buddy and just
look at the navigation board too because
i was so bored i just wanted to look at
numbers slowly just like creeping around
can you see gates in the water
sir it's the hudson nothing is visible
so all these people that are above them
looking down are going to see the
bubbles this would be an example of
where a closed circuit would be better
than open circuit because even though
that guy grabbed him right under water
every time they exhale the bubbles are
coming up it's actually really easy to
track diver's progress
from above when they're breathing open
circuit open circuit you can see the
bubbles closed circuit you can be sneaky
it's just a closed loop system that only
allows the gas to flow through in one
direction because obviously you wouldn't
want it coming back and forth and you
push it through a chemical scrubber it
pulls out the carbon dioxide and boom
you're off and running there's 100
chance that you could actually do that
but if you wanted to do it and actually
not be seen i'd say closed circuit is a
better option i'll give them a
seven
conserve your gas supply speak only when
necessary
it has gonna have to be a radio there's
no way it's gonna be a bluetooth
connection um i have no experience with
doing that there's not really anybody
that you would be talking to nor do i
know what you would necessarily talk
about the diving that we did
was hand signal based or you'd have a
grease pencil
and a piece of plastic and you could
write on it
other than that it was squeezes or just
it's amazing actually how much
you can learn what the other person is
saying you're almost actually holding a
conversation so very low speed even if
something went wrong the number one
thing you do is you stop the dive and
you go to the surface because you can
take the stuff out of your mouth and be
like hey man what's going on and you can
restart the dive
yeah that's real sharks like to go and
stuff too when things would bump into me
the theory that i went with
was if i don't look it didn't happen
so we would be swimming around a lot of
times at night and and i would get
slammed and my whole thought process was
nope i'm not i'm not gonna look at that
i'm gonna pretend that it didn't happen
probably it probably was like a sea lion
you know it could have been a a dolphin
it might have been a shark i don't know
i didn't look i would say
that everything that they did
is possible
they may not have had all the right
equipment to do it but i'll give him a
seven
so it requires
different equipment often times
even to get into these cave systems
it's a very
high risk high consequence
activity hard pass
[Music]
they decided that they were gonna buddy
breathe which is just basically sharing
one apparatus between
two people
if you're gonna do that you're gonna
have to do more than just sit there and
buddy breathe until your oxygen or air
is gone because you noticed they were
staying in exactly the same spot so you
could just sit there and do that and
then run out of air and die together or
her
maybe buddy breathe and start making
your way towards how you can get the
hell out of there
buddy breathing
can kind of go exactly like it went in
this movie people's ability to hold
their breath
varies greatly
and when the regulator is in your mouth
or the mask is on your face and you're
breathing you feel a lot better
than the person who is holding their
breath watching you breathe wishing that
they were breathing wanting the mask
that you're wearing
so it can become a little bit of a
battle but you have to work together you
follow the procedure regardless if
you're scared
cold wet hungry tired
fill in the blank or everything in
between people can get very emotionally
involved in those situations where what
they really need to do is procedurally
work through it as opposed to allowing
their emotions
to take over and you have to work as a
team yeah it would be one of the worst
case scenarios to have something happen
like that not the way that i would want
to go out for sure i'm going to give
that a seven so if you like this video
and you wanna see more do me a favor and
click the link that's above my head